i have been
more than fair to joe biden
for the record
compared i think to any other
conservative commentator pundit talk
show host politician
i have tried to be as charitable as i
possibly can be to him i don't think
that it's fair to blame him for
everything in afghanistan or even most
things in afghanistan i don't think it's
fair to blame him that there was any
chaos or violence in the withdrawal i
think some chaos and perhaps even some
violence were probably inevitable but
he has bungled this
as much as possible
every single step of the way to quote
barack obama don't underestimate how
much joe can f things up and he has and
then he finally addressed the nation
last night he was late to the address
and it was i
it was it was the worst presidential
speech i've ever seen in my lifetime
haven't been on this earth too long but
31 years been paying attention to
politics the whole time is the worst
i've ever seen it was slurred it was
lethargic it was meandering it was weak
it refused to take responsibility
just the open
just
listen to how he begins the speech
a tough day
this evening in kabul as you all know
terrorists
attacked
that we've been talking about and
worried about
that the intelligence community
has assessed uh has undertaken
an attack by a group known as isis k
is he awake is he even awake here or is
he just talking this that's what i sound
like when i talk in my sleep
and um i
[Music]
not a good way to start
it and it does matter i'm not just
taking a cheap shot at him when the
united states is attacked when u.s
servicemen are killed by terrorists in a
completely
avoidable and bungled
military operation
you need some energy from the
commander-in-chief you need some clarity
you need some force and he didn't bring
it
then he confused the whole issue
by referring to
the the distinction between the taliban
and isis and how did isis get back here
i thought we'd beat isis and what is the
taliban doing and what's the
relationship he left more questions than
answers
we've been made aware
by our intelligence community
that the isis k
an arch enemy
the taliban people who were freed when
both those prisons
were opened
has been planning a complex set of
attacks on the united states personnel
and others
first of all enough with the taliban
enough he calls them the taliban every
single time
only democrats do this the
conservatives refer to the taliban
because we speak english but but the
democrats refer to the taliban and
pakistan and all these other stupid and
muslim not muslim muslim because they
want to sound cultured or cosmopolitan
these are the sort of people who
probably go to italian restaurants and
instead of saying hey i'll have the uh
the
spaghetti you know could you give me a
plate of the spaghetti they'll say oh
thank you i would have yi spaghetti
no actually they don't do that they just
do it with certain words that are
non-western and and they think that this
makes them more serious
and cultured it does not
speak english get the point out there
taliban the taliban and isis and their
arch enemies and they the isis guys got
out when those prisons were opened up
who opened to the prisons joe the
taliban opened the prisons the taliban
opened the prisons to free the taliban
people but then the isis people got out
too so are they arch enemies are they
kind of working together do they have a
common enemy in the united states all of
the above but now i guess we're told
that the taliban are our allies
which just
proves the point
what the liberal imperialists who have
been pushing this endless war in
afghanistan have been telling us is that
look we've got to go there there's the
good guys there that that's the afghan
army it's the allies and there's the bad
guys that's the taliban we're fighting
them we've got to kill them all and then
then they'll have peace in afghanistan
and then yesterday we get attacked not
by the taliban but by isis that's
another group and isis is against the
taliban so now we've got to completely
switch and say no actually the taliban
they're our allies they're our friends
here the afghan army doesn't exist just
completely folded within hours so that
doesn't exist anymore now we're friends
with the taliban so what are we doing
what are we doing getting out is what
we're doing
joe biden meanders through this
ridiculous speech longer and longer i
won't subject you to it then he goes and
finally takes some questions from the
press
so is he taking a a rousing round of
combative questions for you know in real
time no
he actually you gotta gotta give him
credit for transparency he acknowledges
that the questions are pre-approved
ladies and gentlemen
he gave me a list here
the first person i was instructed to
call on was
kelly o'donnell of nbc
you have said leaving
afghanistan is in the national interest
of the united states
they gave me a list here
i have been instructed to call on
instructed by whom
who are they
who tell you to do this
they
the people who instructed you to do this
are running the country you manifestly
are not
and you're not even competent enough to
hide the fact that all of this is a show
and it's all pre-approved
more on that in a minute but first the
economy is all over the place these days
prices are going way way up and the most
solid asset that most people have is
like a dogecoin i would recommend you
hedge
with gold gold always has had value it's
tangible it's physical great hedge on
inflation an acre will let you
invest in physical gold
for as little as 30 bucks a month
michael you liar don't call me a liar
gold is more expensive michael calm down
calm
down acre figured it out for as little
as 30 a month you subscribe you pay each
month once your gold stash reaches the
price of their gold bars it will
discreetly ship acre gold to your house
they've got a new hundred dollar a month
subscription to a five gram gold bar you
don't need to come out of pocket all at
once i have always enjoyed and done very
well investing in physical precious
metals i love investing in acre gold
specifically i got my bar sitting right
on my desk at home visit getting i
probably shouldn't have told you that
now someone's going to break into my
house visit
getacregold.com start investing in
physical gold today make sure you go to
this url because acre is giving away a
gold bar to qualify for the giveaway
tweet or post why you should be the
recipient and mention at get underscore
acre that's getacre gold.com knowles
thank you acre gold for supporting the
show
he then is asked
actually an excellent reporter here
uh it's hard to tell who these reporters
are because they've got their masks on
but he's he he asks him about bagram he
says hold on this is the question that
my wife asked the other day my wife who
says i'm no foreign policy expert okay i
didn't go to west point but
when you're leaving a country wouldn't
it be smart to get the civilians out
before the military leaves wouldn't that
be a smart idea i don't know maybe i'm
crazy so
this reporter asks that question
did you personally reject a
recommendation to hold or to recapture
bagram air force base
here's what i've done on the let's ask
answer the last question first
on the tactical questions of how to
conduct
an evacuation or a war
i gather up
all the major military personnel
that are in afghanistan the commanders
as well as the pentagon
and i ask for their best military
judgment
what would be
the most efficient way to accomplish the
mission
they concluded the military
that bagram
was not
much value added that it was much wiser
to focus on
kabul
and so i followed that recommendation
was that i actually couldn't tell was
that wegman i think it may have been
excellent question really excellent
question terrible answer but really good
question to ask him hold on was this
your decision are you the buck stops
with you is the are you the one who made
this call to abandon the air base before
before the air lift doesn't make sense
and what does biden do it's so pathetic
he blames his commanders
he says no they
they gave me the advice and so i did
what they wanted me to do it's their
fault
don't blame the buck stops with them
they're the president it's not my no
buddy your
your job is to get advice from a lot of
different people
and then either choose
whose advice you want to go with or come
up with a separate answer yourself
you're the decider whatever you want to
say about george bush i think george w
bush made a lot of mistakes and i think
a lot of the problems in afghanistan are
because of him and a lot of the
confusion in our foreign policy is
because of him but
whatever you want to say about george
bush at least he was the decider at
least he owned his decisions and stood
by them
kind of proof that that sometimes a
wrong decision even can be better than
indecision
biden won't do that he's got to blame
everybody but
himself
peter ducey one of the last reporters
left in america reported for fox news he
gets up
asks biden
a question about responsibility
listen mr president you've been dancing
around and evading responsibility for
this whole
debacle
is this uh do you take responsibility
for any aspect of the collapse of
afghanistan
you set a deadline you pulled troops out
you sent troops back in
and now 12 marines are dead you said the
buck stops with you do you bear any
responsibility
for the way that things have unfolded in
the last two weeks i bear responsibility
for
fundamentally all that's happened
of late
but here's the deal
you know i wish you one day say these
things you know as well as i do
that the former president
made a deal with the taliban
that he would get all american forces
out of afghanistan by may 1.
in return the commitment was made and
that was a year before
in return he was given a commitment
that the taliban
would continue to attack
others but would not attack any american
forces
look fundamentally the the problem it
all comes back to me i'm responsible
but it was trump's fault this democrats
always do this they say i'm taking full
responsibility but really we all know it
was someone else's fault so they're
trying to get credit for taking
responsibility but they evade
responsibility entirely by the way this
raises a question a lot of this debacle
is because we're pushing down to the end
of august or maybe even
later
if if the whole point was that they were
going to get the troops out by early may
why didn't they do that
if what biden is saying is yeah you know
a lot of the reason that this is so
violent there are attacks and everything
is because
we stayed longer and that's why the
taliban's not going to give us another
extension why didn't you just get out
when when the united states said we
would then
wouldn't we have avoided this then
if you're saying that a lot of the
reason that the taliban had not been
attacking american troops is because of
trump's deal then why wouldn't you
continue with that
and then the worst moment of the press
conference then we can move on but the
worst moment of the press conference do
not let the left spin this they're
already spinning this as he was asked to
follow up by peter ducey and biden was
so defeated that he just put his head
down on his hands
because before
no no no wait a minute i'm asking you a
question is that accurate the best about
mr president respectfully
i don't think that the issue that do you
think that people have an issue with
pulling out of afghanistan or just the
way the things that happen
so pathetic he can't he can't even keep
his head up he can't even keep his eyes
open i mean he was struggling to do that
during the speech itself and now ducey
pushes back at all very simple question
and he puts his head down on his hands
the left is spinning this image this is
a devastating image for the biden
administration and the left is already
spinning it and saying that he was
praying for our troops that's not what
what happened you just heard the clip
he was not he was struggling and failing
to answer a simple question by a
reporter
earlier in the speech he said let's have
a moment of silence but he did that's
not what that image is from don't let
this had a blue check mark yesterday
tell me oh no michael you're so callous
to make fun of this moment he's praying
for the fallen servicemen he's not
he's praying that the reporter will stop
asking him tough questions and he's
praying that he can get an answer to it
but he can't because there is no answer
the chances that this guy gets reelected
are collapsing day and day after day
after day after day unless there's
widespread voter fraud in 2024
[Music]
you